sens public continue avec un second
débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour consacré au sans
abri en France sont-ils toujours plus
nombreux les promesses politiques de Z0
SDF sont-elles impossibles à tenir
faut-il donner au maire le pouvoir de
réquisitionner les logements vides avant
de répondre à ces questions le reportage
de Samia de chir et Fabien REER sur un
phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur les
femmes seules qui dorment à la
rue cela fait bientôt un mois qu'edv
s'est retrouvé dehors du jour au
lendemain arrivé illégalement de Côte
d'Ivoire l'an dernier elle était logée
chez sa sœur qu' l'a mise à la porte en
décembre dernier suite à une dispute
quand l'histoire s'est passée qu'elle
m'a mise dehors j'ai pensé que à la
longue elle allait revenir à de
meilleurs sentiments je banalisais c'est
quand je suis restée jusqu'à 1h min 1h
c'est là je me suis rendue compte donc
la première solution que j'ai eu c'est
de puisque je voyais aussi des gens dans
les métos qui dormaient je dit bon je
vais aussi aller
essayer donc c'est dans la ligne 4 là
que je suis allée m'asseoir je suis
restée comme ça assise jusqu'au petit
matin pourquoi on a peur cont on est
deors le
viol parce que la femme elle est sans
défense et le plus souvent les gens les
les les gens sont sous sous l'effet de
de la drogue des nuits sans sommeil
angoissé par la peur d'une
agression impossible de retourner en
Côte d'Ivoire elle y a laissé ses qu
enfants après avoir perdu son mari et
son emploi en l'espace d'un mois c'est
pour subvenir à leur besoin qu'elle est
venue ici dans l'espoir de trouver un
travail tous les jours elle appelle le
115 pour tenter de trouver une place en
hébergement
d'urgence5 abri l'équipe du 115 est là
pour vous informer et vous orienter
merci de patienter il peut faire 1 heure
sans décrocher 2h sans décrocher donc on
est obligé de laisser le téléphone comme
ça sonner parce que tu sais pas à quel
moment ils vont décrocher hier j'ai eu
la chance vers 9h là ils ont décroché je
leur a même dit que j'étais malade que
j'ai le
rhumatisme que je suis fatiguée de dormi
dehors ils m'ont dit désolé qu'il
n'avait pas de place don la journée
edvich trouve refuge à la haltefemme
gérée par l'association Aurore dans le
12e arrondissement parisien ici elles
peuvent prendre un petit- déjeuner une
douche laver leur linge et rencontrer
des travailleurs sociaux tous les jours
nous sommes solliicité les femmes
viennent nous voir en nous disant je
suis à la rue nous avons des femmes
âgées des femmes malades
sous-traitement qui viennent nous nous
voir en disant on m'a orienté chez vous
pour avoir un hébergement sauf que nous
n'avons pas d'hébergement nous n'avons
rien rien voilà nous sommes tous
démunis je pense que l'ensemble des
travailleurs sociaux sont
démunis à bientôt
Vig à demain à 15h
Vich se dépêche de rejoindre la porte de
la Villette au nord de Paris dans le
froid sans aucun endroit où s'asseoir
elle attend longuement le bus qui passe
chaque soir à 17h en direction d'un
centre d'hébergement un enterre celles
et ceux à qui le 115 n'a pas trouvé de
place peuvent y passer la nuit les
femmes sont prioritaires mais si elle
rate ce bus elle devra de nouveau passer
la nuit dehors plus le jour avance et tu
es stressé pour ne pas rater le cas et
là quand tu rates le cas imaginez la
suite avec le froid c'est vraiment
difficile très très
difficile moi j'ai pas de couverture
j'ai que mon manteau c'est vrai que j'ai
le sourire mais c'est pas facile par
moment quand tu te retrouves seul tu as
des pleurs d'après le dernier
recensement 3000 personnes vivent à la
rue à Paris parmi elles 10 % de femmes
contre 2 % il y a 10 ans notez que la
version longue de ce reportage de Samia
de et Fabien r sera diffusé le samedi 2
mars à 18h30 sur notre antenne sur
Public Sénat 0 SDF la promesse intenable
c'est le thème de notre débat avec
christophe Robert bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes délégué général de la Fondation
abépierre Yanne brossa bonsoir et
bienvenue sénateur communiste de Paris
ancienne adjoint au logement à la méie
Paris Julien Damont bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes sociologue enseignant à
science pot et h CHC émil zapalski
éditorialiste pour sens publque et
rester à mes côtés je commence par le le
le constat ce chiffre donné par la
Fondation Abé piierre qui est celui de
33001 domicile fixe la situation
s'est-elle aggravée en 2023 christophe
Robert difficile de dire parce qu'il y a
en fait pas eu d'enquête Inc depuis 2012
h euh donc nous on avait actualisé les
chiffres de l'INC l'année passée mais
ces données qui sont agrégées pour
qualifier ces personnes sans domicile
fixe qui ne veut pas dire tout sans
abriis hein il y a une partie des
sansabriis une partie qui sont en
hébergement d'urgence donc c'est un
doublement depuis 2012 mais on peut pas
les faire évoluer chaque année parce que
nous n'avons pas les statistiques
publiques pour le faire on y reviendra
avec Quentin Calmet tout à l'heure sur
l'absence de de chiffr en c'est quand
même un doublement 10 ans c'est ça qu'
faut retenir et alors puisqu'on fait un
peu de pédagogie sans abri sans domicile
fixe la différence alors nous on reprend
les définitions de de l'INS les
personnes qui vont être sans abri c'est
des personnes qui vont vraiment dormir
dehors sous un Porsche dans un dans un
jardin public euh et quand vous
élargissez la focale pour aller vers la
définition des personnes sans domicile
vous pouvez avoir des personnes qui sont
en centre d'hébergement d'urgence qui
peuvent être en centre d'accueil pour
demandeur d'asile donc qui sont des
réponses temporaires hein c'est pas des
solutions durables de logement c'est pas
des des solutions dignes donc c'est des
personnes sans toit et qui peuvent du
jour au lendemain être bah se retrouver
à la rue ou rester dans l'hébergement
d'urgence tout dépend ou Yan bossa vous
êtes devenu conseiller de Paris en 2008
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment d'une
d'une lame de fond d'une sorte de
progression régulière ou alors vous
voyez quand même le lien entre le
contexte économique général et la
situation justement du du sansabrisme il
y a en tout cas une augmentation très
nette ces dernières années du nombre de
personnes à la rue on en parlera tout à
l'heure je crois mais la ville de Paris
a lancé un décompte annuel du nombre de
personnes à la rue et de fait il y a une
augmentation ce qui me frappe aussi
c'est le le le changement de de de
typologie des personnes qui sont dehors
on voit par exemple de plus en plus
d'enfants on a dans Paris aujourd'hui
environ 400 enfants scolarisés
identifiés qui tous les matins vont à
l'école en ayant passé la nuit dehors ça
c'est un phénomène qu'on ne voyait pas
il y a encore quelques années et
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas un phénomène
proprement parisien puisqu'on le voit
dans d'autres grande métropole à Lyon
par exemple ça c'est un changement qu'on
a vu ces dernières années
incontestablement ouais Julien Damon
justement sur le les caractéristiques en
quelque sorte la la la sociologie de
cette population de de s domicile fixe
aujourd'hui plus de femmes plus de
famille qu'auparavant on peut dire ça
assurément mais il faut aussi aborder le
sujet le plus sensible c'est que un des
principaux changement c'est le lié au
faits migratoires il y a une trentaine
d'années quand vous vous occupiez de la
question des sansabris les gens ple à la
rue il fallait parler français il y a
une vingtaine d'années crise du bloc
soviétique oblige il fallait parler un
peu de langue de l'Est du russe ou du
polonais aujourd'hui dans Paris il faut
parler toutes les langues du monde le
sujet des sans-abriis est aujourd'hui un
sujet qui est pleinement en lien avec le
chaos du monde et avec les flux
migratoires plus ou moins bien gérés
donc c'est pas faire une typologique des
sans abriis de vous dire c mais par
rapport à ce qui était évoqué je pense
qu'il ne faut jamais oublier cette
dimension maintenant majeure christop
c'est dimension que vous devez prendre
en compte aujourd'hui oui tout à fait
euh alors il y a plusieurs choses on on
sait avec les enquêtes Inc quel ont été
les évolutions alors vous allez dire il
y en a eu deux c'est 2002 2012 la
prochaine est en 2025 ça sera très
important parce qu'il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses les chaos du monde
mais les chaos sociaux aussi dans notre
pays des fragilisations des outils de
protection des difficultés même
l'inflation depuis 2 an plus 20 % des
produits alimentaires prix de l'énergie
on on voit plusieurs choses donc entre
les deux derniers enquêes de l'INC on
voit une augmentation des femmes très
clairement et je crois que ces dernières
années on le mesure la moins avec les
enquêtes de l'INC que nous n'avons pas
mais avec les appels aux 115 de
personnes donc qui appellent à qui on ne
propose pas de solution mais on avait
déjà vu une augmentation du nombre de
femmes dans les deux enquêtes et une
augmentation de personnes étrangères
effectivement entre 2002 et 2012 sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on est incapable de
qualifier le nombre de personnes à la
rue qui serait lié à l'exil par exemple
de pays qu'il fut la guerre ou de la
misère
avec un point quand même c'est que si le
secteur de l'hébergement d'urgence qui
n'a cessé d'augmenter en fait au fil de
ces 15 dernières années parce que les
besoins étaient là c'est souvent les
défaillances d'autres politiques
publiques qui sont en cause par exemple
vous avez beaucoup de personnes il y a
une surreprésentation des jeunes qui
sortent de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
que nous avons protégé pendant des
années et qui n'ont pas de solution de
logement quand ils sortent à 18 19 20 21
ans et puis vous avez par exemple aussi
sur le fait migratoire des personnes qui
sont en demande d'asile là je parle de
la partie des demandeurs d'asile qui ne
trouvent pas de place en centre
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile alors
du coup ils vont frapper ces personnes
vont frapper à la porte de l'hébergement
d'urgence dit généraliste si vous voulez
donc ce cet espace là qui est
l'ébergement d'urgence qui est le le
dernier recours pour quelqu'un qui se
retrouve à la rue et aussi le témoin
d'un certain nombre de défaillance
d'autres politiqu publ c'est au bout de
l'effet domino en quelque sorte en amont
et on avale les difficultés à sortir
vers des solutions plus dignes et
durbles de logement et bien rendu
difficile fait que les personnes y
restent il me semble que c'est aussi
probablement quand on pourra faire le
compte puisque comme vous dites c'est
pas fait régulièrement c'est un peu la
phase cachée du covid de la crise covid
la phase cachée de la crise énergétique
là comme si on ne repérait pas c'est la
même chose pour les entreprises qui
risquent d'être en difficulté certaines
ou certains artisans ou petites comme
s'il y avait les conséquences qu'on n'
pas forcément vu parce qu'il y a des
gens qui ont été soutenus d'autres qui
ont pas pu être soutenus et certains
dont on a même pas la trace finalement
et qui peuvent être amenés à des
situations très difficiles vous parlez
des femmes c'est vrai que a il y a
beaucoup plus de familles qui décrochent
qui sont séparé et beaucoup plus de
conditions très difficiles et
probablement c'est une espèce de face
cachée qu'on risque de découvrir dans
les années qui viennent terribl avec des
situations beaucoup plus dégradées avant
ces crises mais qu'on repère pas encore
totalement ouai alors après la la
question de de la politique du logement
et de la place de des des sans-abris
dans cette politique du logement on va
on va y consacrer un chapitre important
mais je voudrais rebondir ce que vous
disiez sur le nombre d'enfants vous
disiez 400 enfants à Paris le chiffre
que donne l'UNICEF pour la France c'est
3000 enfants à la rue souvent en danger
comme l'explique le directeur adjoint du
groupement abri on écoute Augustin
malisson parfois certains résidents nous
ont même dit ben oui j'ai accepté que
les enfants aillent dormir avec un
monsieur que j'ai croisé pour pour la
nuit au moins ils sont été au chaud et
on se pose la question de à quelle
conditions quelle contreparttie et Cera
voilà ce sont des des mises en danger de
ces personnes des dangers de rue ce
qu'on appelle danger de rue qui sont qui
sont évidents et qui sont de plus en
plus
important si on je pas demander une
liste mais les dangers de rue qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière cette expression vol
viol violence agression enfin la rue est
évidemment l'endroit où pour des enfants
il est absolument indigne de dormir et
pour des adultes absolument indigne de
vivre quand on parle de la violence de
la rue c'est que au quotidien vous vous
avez des personnes qui sont obligées
pour vivre et survivre bah d'être au
contact avec des des des d'autres
personnes qui peuvent chercher à leur
piquer leur RSA aller voler et cetera et
cetera donc la vie à la rue est
évidemment la vie la plus dure mais je
je reviens sur votre expérience à la
mairie de Paris parce que quand on est
en charge du logement comme vous vous
avez pas laissé vous êtes pas resté
inerte évidemment une une famille avec
des enfants une femme avec seule avec un
un un enfant elle est censée être quoi
prioritaire sur certaines offre de
d'hébergement comment ça se passe oui
bien sûr il y a des priorités après
l'hébergement d'urgence ça reste une
compétence de de l'État quand on est en
présence de familles qui ne sont pas en
situation régulière elles ne peuvent
même pas et ça se comprend déposer une
demande de logement sociale donc de fait
elles dépendent de l'hébergement la
seule possibilité qu'elles ont c'est
d'être hébergé donc c'est c'est c'est à
l'état de le faire après bien sûr qu'il
y a des priorités simplement aujourd'hui
on a un hébergement d'urgence qui est
tellement saturé qu'on est amené à faire
des priorités qui sont parfois
ahurissantes c'est-à-dire considérer
qu'un mum de 2 ans est prioritaire par
rapport à un mum de 3 ans on en arrive à
faire des des arbitrages qui sont euh
proprement proprement effrayants euh et
donc tout ça traduit je trouve quand
même la la crise générale dans laquelle
on est où toute la chaîne de
l'hébergement et du logement est
aujourd'hui complètement grippée les les
euh son domicile fi dont dont on parle
alors c'est c'est pas le plus important
mais je pense que pour eux c'est très
très important ils sont aussi fragilisés
Christ Robert par la fin des titres
restaurants papier et puis le fait qu'on
paye de moins en moins en cash est-ce
que vous le vous entendez ces retours
d'expérience oui alors on est sur un
autre registre que celui dont on est en
train de parler effectivement c'est la
débrouille c'est une débrouille qui est
rendue plus difficile mais c'est une des
difficulté de la manière que chacun de
vos auditeurs peut comprendre que c'est
plus difficile de donner un tick resto à
son fils ou à sa fille il y a il y a ce
risque là avec la dématérialisation qui
qui est en cours effectivement ou Julien
Damon c'est marqué ça absolument
c'est-à-dire que là on ne parle pas des
sansabris on parle des gens qui font la
manche et parmi les gens qui font la
manche il n'y a pas que des sansabris et
tous les sansabris ne font pas la Manche
vous avez raison c'est important de le
préciser mais cette dématérialisation a
un impact sur les ressources des gens
qui ne peuvent plus recevoir dans leur
boîte de camber ou en tendant la main ou
après un petit spectacle après une
petite œuvre d'art un ou 2 € ou un
ticket restaurant oui sans que ce soit
massif sans surtout que ce soit
mesurable une nouvelle fois c'est
quelque chose qui remonte des
expériences dont nous font part les gens
les gens concernés alors c'est
passionnant ce ce débat parce que on
parle de politique publique on va
essayer de se poser la question d'une
bonne politique publique sauf que depuis
le début on et vous avez commencé par ça
on se dit on n pas vraiment des données
officielles suffisamment fiables je
propose à Quentin calm de de nous
rejoindre parce que on va expliquer ça
en détail Quentin et puis peut-être
effectivement rentrer dans dans ce qui a
été mis en place à la à la mairie de
Paris donc aucune estimation officielle
he récente du nombre de sans abris en
France effectivement Thomas pourtant
l'INC depuis 2001 l'Institut de
statistique a mis en place une enquête
avec des données des lieux qui
accueillent des personnes pour évaluer
le nombre de personnes sans domicile
fixe les dernières données vous
l'évoquez dans votre première partie du
débat elle date de 2012 l'INS qui
estimait alors le nombre de personnes
sans domicile fixe à 143000 des chiffres
actualisés 330000 a dit à la Fondation
abépierre mais donc ces données de l'INC
sont anciennes la méthode est
perfectible et surtout ces chiffres
prennent en compte les personnes passées
par des centres d'accueil il est encore
plus difficile Thomas de recenser le nom
de personnes qui ne font même pas appel
à l'aide sociale les sans abri le Sénat
examine demain une proposition de loi je
crois qu'elle vient du Parti socialiste
pour justement mieux compter le nombre
de sansabris en France voilà l'idée est
d'organiser Thomas un décompte annuel
dans chaque commune de plus de 100000
habitants en France les socialistes
s'appuient sur une expérience réalisée à
Paris depuis 2018 la nuit de la
solidarité se tient en janvier 2000
travailleurs sociaux et bénévoles
parcourent la capitale pour recenser le
nombre de sans abri dans les rues de
Paris ils étaient 3000 cet hiver là
l'hiver 2018 c'est le même chiffre à peu
près lors du décompte de janvier 2023 et
puis au-delà du d'un chiffrage plus
rigoureux il y a beaucoup d'autres
avantages aussi d'autres intérêts oui
quatre objectifs avec ces nuit de la
solidarité qui sont tenus dans 16 villes
de plus de 100000 habitants l'an dernier
déjà il y a le fait de mieux connaître
les profils des sansabris les Marode
elle s'arrête pour recueillir des
données auprès des sansabris qui ne
dorment pas également le fait de R
forcer la visibilité des sansabris
également mobiliser informer les
citoyens et enfin créer une structure
d'échange entre les acteurs état
collectivité association et cette nuit
de la solidarité elle a apporté un
certain nombre de détails justement
concernant les sans-abris oui regardez
les statistiques recueilliis
effectivement parmi les 3015 personnes
sans abri 60 % sont sans abri depuis
plus d'un an 77 n'appellent plus le 115
9 % sont des femmes Thomas une
information intéressante car à l'INC qui
réalisait donc les recensements on le
disait elle tablait sur 1 % de femes ce
qui montre l'importance de cette
initiative pour aussi adapter la
politique publique le texte examiné en
séance demain vise donc à étendre et
rendre obligatoire de tels décomptes
dans toutes les grandes villes de France
th merci beaucoup on reviendra
évidemment sur la question du 115 qui
qui nous semble importante Yan brossa
depuis cette première nuit de la
solidarité que que que disent les
chiffres en quelque sorte une
progression constante pas pas constante
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
làdessus les chiffres disent une
augmentation du nombre de de personnes à
la rue ce que ce que je trouve important
euh c'est que ce sont aussi des
décomptes qui nous ont permis d'adapter
dans un certain nombre de domaines nos
politiques publiques par exemple on
évoquait la question des femmes c'est
notamment parce qu'on a organisé la nuit
de la solidarité qu'on a repéré un
nombre en augmentation de femmes à la
rue qu'on a ouvert par exemple en
partenariat avec l'état des haltes de
nuit spécifiquement dédié aux femmes y
compris d'ailleurs au sein même de
l'hôtel de ville et dans plusieurs
mairies d'arrondissement on l' vu d'
d'ailleurs dans votre reportage dans le
12e arrondissement de Paris ça c'est
très important c'est-à-dire que cette
proposition de loi elle va nous
permettre de réaliser un décompte dans
toutes les villes de plus de 100000
habitants mais derrière il faut en tirer
un certain nombre de conséquences si
c'est juste pour établir un décompte ça
n'a pas grand intérêt et donc tout ça
doit être suivi d'acte pour tenter de
remédier au problème mais en tout cas je
pense que c'est une proposition de loi
utile christophe Robert moi j'aiétéis
très surpris de de découvrir
qu'effectivement il y avait pas de
statistique officielle je comprends que
c'est ça peut être une une population
difficile à à recenser mais quand même
comment mener une politique publique
efficace si on sait pas si le constat
est pas partagé et et établi voyez ce
que je veux dire complètement je vois
très bien ce que vous voulez dire et je
suis complètement d'accord avec ce que
vous venez de dire c'est-à-dire que
c'est un vrai problème on agit une faç
de le cacher non je vais vous dire une
chose ce que je pense c'est que l'INS a
très peu de moyens trop peu de moyens
mais on voit d'ailleurs he sur la
connaissance une évolution plutôt de
dégradation en dégradation si vous
voulez le nombre de projets de loi qu'on
a vu ces dernières années sans étude
d'impact par exemple nous pose nous à la
Fondation abpierre un vrai problème
enfin à moment quand on met en place des
politiques public ou quand on met en
place des études c'est pour pouvoir
faire évoluer nos politiques publiques
les adapter ou faire changer les
politiques ça veut dire qu'on a en tête
que ça va avoir tel ou tel effet donc il
y a un déficit qui nous inquiète
beaucoup peut-être qu'il y a une
tentation de mettre un peu les choses
sous le tapis donc c'est important qu'on
puisse continuer cette connaissance avec
si on est sur la connaissance deux
choses les nuits de la solidarité doncon
a plutôt encouragé d'ailleurs il y a
après la première initiative de la
Mairie de Paris vous l'avez dit d'autres
villes qui se sont engagé dans cette
voie làà d'essayer d'harmoniser les
méthodologies mais ça n'est pas non plus
le même travail que fait lins c'està-d
ça donne une photographie à un moment
mais lin fait un travail de qualité nous
permettent par exemple de comprendre
pourquoi les personnes sont à la rue
est-ce que c'est parce que c'est lié à
des vagues migratoires est-ce que c'est
parce que c'est lié à des personnes qui
sortent de prison sans logement des
personnes expulsées de leur logement en
gros vous savez si vous pouvez il faut
l'incer pour le savoir enta oui parce
que là vous menez des enquêtes prof
approfondies qui permettent de savoir
quel est le parcours des personnes quel
a été pourquoi elles sont dans la rue
depuis combien de temps quels ont été
les phénomènes de rupture on voit par
exemple dans tous les situations qui
conduisent les personnes à la rue que à
un moment les politiques publiques ont
aidé ces personnes et c'est dommage de
ne pas avoir réussi à les accompagner
dans la durée si on les connaissait pas
je je dirais que ce serait difficile
mais on voit bien parce queà un moment
vous étiz à l're sociale enfant je le
disais parce qu' moment vous étiez C
pour demandur d'asile à un moment vous
étiez en prison à un moment vous avez
été expulsé donc le préfet a décidé de
vous expulser on pourrait débloquer dans
ces moments de rupture des politiques
beaucoup plus protectrice et alors à
quel niveau quel est le bon niveau
Julien Damont est-ce que c'est c'est
finalement vous on a vu nuit de la
solidarité dans des communes de plus de
100000 habitants certaines l'ont déjà
fait après et à la question de de la
compétence c'est la mairie c'est pas la
mairie c'est quoi le bon le bon échant
administratif voyez pour régler
finalement les les questions liées au
sansabriis en France mon sentiment c'est
qu'en France ceci est trop centralisé
trop confié à l'état et que ceci devrait
être donc davantage décentralisé
davantage confié aux collectivités
locales ça empêcherait ce jeu de
pingpong incessant qui consiste pour les
villes à dire c'est l'état et pour
l'État à dire oui mais si les villes ne
s'impliquent pas on ne fera pas bien
pourquoi je pense cela c'est parce que
ailleurs en Europe là où cela fonctionne
mieux ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
là-bas encore des gens à la rue mais là
où Onon ne s'est trip pas quand à savoir
combien il y a de personnes à la rue
est-ce qu'il y a suffisamment de moyens
et bien ce sont les collectivités
locales les grandes collectivités
locales qui s'en occup qu'il s'agisse de
pays libéraux comme le Royaume-Uni ou
qu'il s'agisse de pays qui nous
ressemblent davantage comme l'Allemagne
l'Espagne ou toute chos égal par
ailleurs l'Italie ce que je voudrais
dire sur les chiffres quand même pour
nuancer un peu c'est qu'on a beaucoup
progressé même si c'est très imparfait
c'est nuit de la solidarité ça amène des
chiffres qui sans être incontestable
parce que il sera toujours impossible de
dire qu'on a vraiment touché tout le
monde ça donne un ordre de grandeur du
nombre de personnes qui dortent deh de
grandeur à Paris plutôt stable tout dire
que oui il nous reste beaucoup de choses
à faire ça c'est les Nui de la
solidarité sur les sans aru la deuxième
chose sur les autres sans domicile les
gens qui sont dans les centre
d'hébergement ce que fait à juste titre
la Fondation abé-pierre pour le
caricaturer mais c'était ce que je dis
Texa c'est qu'en fait on compte un
nombre de places d'hébergement en France
vous avez plus de 300000 places
d'hébergement et donc vous navez pas
300000 personnes qui sont sans domicile
un soir donné oui mais sur une année
vous en avez beaucoup plus et le plus
difficile c'est d'arriver
statistiquement à saisir ces flux h si
on regarder ça sur le temps d'une vie il
y a des enquêtes aussi sont
intéressantes où on pose la question au
population générale c'estàd à tout le
monde et on dit est-ce qu'un jour vous
avez été contraint de dormir dehors ou
dans un centre d'hébergement et là vous
avez plus de 1 % de la population
française qui a été concernée alors vous
voyez que on va de quelques milliers de
personnes à jusqu'à 600000 personnes qui
peuvent avoir un jour été concernées et
je pense que là-dessus on voit à peu
près où on en est et que le thème le
plus important c'est de savoir quelle
décision radicale on doit prendre pour
que ce système fonctionne mieux une
décision radicale à mon avis ça porte
sur les S papiers parce que on peut se
cacher derrière nos doigts nos oreilles
tout ce que l'on veut ce sujet est
majeur vous avez dans les centres
d'hébergement une d'urgence et pas dans
les centres d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale une majorité de
personnes qui sont pour le dire
diplomatiquement en délicatesse avec le
droit de séjour si vous ne traitez pas
le sujet des 100 papiers bah vous
continuerez à mettre de l'argent dans
les machine et ça ne marchera pas y m ça
votre avis là-dessus c'est c'est vrai
c'est c'est un constat que que je ne
peut que partager vous allez aujourd'hui
dans un centre d'hébergement ça m'est
arrivé il y a quelques mois ça m'a
frappé euh chez moi dans le 18e
arrondissement de Paris euh vous rentrez
vous avez effectivement beaucoup de
personnes qui n'ont pas de papier des
personnes qui n'ont pas de papier et qui
travaillent vous verriz le nombre de
sacs à dos dé livrous et uberit à
l'entrée du centre d'hébergement c'est
hallucinant donc on a affaire à des gens
qui sont effectivement sans papier qui
travaillent qui ne seront en réalité
jamais expulsés et donc on est dans une
logique absurde puisque de fait ils
scotch des places d'hébergement ils nt
même pas la possibilité de déposer une
demande de logement social c'est aussi
ce qui fait que moi j'ai estimé dans le
cadre du débat sur le projet de loi
immigration qu'il fallait permettre à
ces personnes d'avoir accès à des
papiers ce qui permettrait justement de
créer une fluidité ils ont accès au
logements social il quitent le centre
d'hébergement mais là de fait le seul
choix qui se présente à ces personnesl
c'est soit la rue soit le centre
d'hébergement c'est évidemment pas
tenable alors il y a cette cette
promesse du Z0 isdf qu'on a entendu dans
la dans la bche d'à peu près tous les
premier ministres et président de la
République depuis 20 25 ans euh Émilie
on peut dire quoi c'est une tentation
pour les gouvernements d'afficher cette
promesse j'ai pris un échantillon je les
sais pas tous cité il y a Lionel Jospin
en campagne pour la présidentielle 2002
il promettait le 0 SDF même chose pour
le candidat Sarkozi 2007 lui président
au bout de 2 ans plus personne ne serait
obligé de dormir sur le trottoir et dit
mourir de froid Emmanuel Macron 2017 le
problème devait être réglé en un an
pourquoi cette promesse n'est-elle
jamais tenue bon bah nos échanges le
montrent c'est difficile de répondre en
un seul avec une seule réponse à ce
problème multifacette qui demande si on
veut vraiment s'y attaquer fixer des
moyens dans le long terme pas forcément
à réagir à l'urgence comme c'est souvent
le cas Macron s'y est collé depuis le
début de son premier quinquena il a fait
un plan logement d'abord qui a été
répété en 2023 516 millions d'euros sur
5 ans pour sortir 400000 personnes de la
rue alors le gouvernement actuel il a
pas de ministre du Logement ça c'est
peut-être aussi un mauvais signal qui a
été
HES associations mais il y a la carte
vain Catherine vain alors cette nouvelle
ministre du Travail de la santé des
soillidarité elle a déjà traité le sujet
c'était sous Sarkozy 2006 je sais pas si
vous en souvenez elle était ministre de
la cohésion sociale il y avait
l'association Les Enfants de Don
quiichot qui avait installé des tentes
dans Paris en plein Paris des campements
de SDF pour attirer justement
l'attention des pouvoirs publics et
l'épisode s'était terminé par un plan de
70 millions d'euros qui avait été
annoncé par Catherine vaurin qui avait
été globalement quand même plutôt
approuvé par les associations d'aide aux
exclus évidemment sauf la plus concernée
les enfants de donquichot par les
enfants de donkichot c'est pas suffisant
alors c'est pas suffisant non par
rapport à l'emploir du problème et et
nos échanges en témoignent encore et ça
dépasse aussi le cadre des des seules
politiques publque alors là je vais sur
un terrain qui est peut-être un peu plus
délicat de l'acceptabilité citoyenne euh
les ouvertures de centres d'hébergement
d'accueil euh font pas toujours des
heureux hein sont pas toujours
accueillis dans la plus grande joie des
comités de quartier s'y opposent même
parfois donc finalement j'ai
l'impression qu'on est loin de la
promesse politique du 0 SDF mais on est
aussi loin du message lancé à la
population en 54 par l'abbé Pierre je
reprends ces mots un partager donne
tendez la main aux autres gardez
toujours un carreau cassé dans vos
univers bien feutrés pour entendre les
plaines qui viennent de l'extérieur je
suis pas sûre que la société soit
toujours dans cet état d'esprit merci
Émilie 0 SDF Julien Damont votre avis
là-dessus promesse jamais tenue mais
est-ce que ça a quand même permis de
faire progresser la politique en en
matière d'aide au au sans-abri euh
promesse jamais tenu absolument maises
belles promesses euh alors les promesses
d'engage que ceux qui les prononc dit-on
mais en l'espèce je trouve que c'est le
plus bel objectif que l'on puisse se
donner et ça chque pas qu'un qu'un
président ou un premier ministre annonce
cet objectif même si depuis ça me ch pas
je pense qu'au contraire il devrait tous
l'annoncer et s'y coller et ne s'y colle
pas forcément on peut venir sur la
généalogie de cet objectif c'est en fait
Tony Blair qui avait souffler ça à
Monsieur Fabius quiavait soufflé ensuite
à Lionel Jospin et ce qui s'est passé
c'est quand Lionel Jospin dans la
campagne présidentielle ou dans la
précampagne comme vous l'évoquiez a
annoncé cet objectif tout le monde lui
est tombé dessus et en particulier le
monde associatif en disant c'est
impossible Mo je me rappelle très très
bienin c'est-à-dire qu'on va rétorquer
qu'est-ce que c'est que cet objectif
c'est démagogique et cetera non c'est je
suis F du
mois on a vérifié ça je pense que ça
n'est absolument pas démagogique que
c'est vraiment les objectifs que l'on
peut se donner je précise que la France
s'est engagé à l'échelle internationale
avec la communauté de tous les pays du
monde à éradiquer la pauvreté personne
n'en sourit de cela personne ne dit ah
on y arrivera pas et cetera et cetera
donc c'est un très bel objectif et si on
n arrive pas c'est parce que précisément
les politiques publiques ne prennent pas
les décisions assez compliqué c'est vrai
radical parfois qui peuvent s'imposer
alors parmi ces ces ces solutions Yan
brossa vous allez déposer le 12 janvier
dernier une proposition de loi vous
souhaitez élargir le pouvoir de
réquisition des logements vides au
pourquoi oui absolument parce que je je
pars d'une forme de de contradiction que
chacun peut constater c'est que on a
d'un côté de plus en plus de personnes
qui dorment à la rue bien identifié dans
un certain nombre de territoires et on a
dans le même temps des bâtiments qui
sont vides et qui sont identifiés eux
aussi parfois depuis des années et
aujourd'hui vous vous retrouvez
effectivement dans un système un peu
absurde où les communes pas toutes mais
un certain nombre de communes demande au
préfet de réquisitionner ces bâtiments
et les préfets disent systéma atiquement
qu'il ne réquisitionne que si les
propriétaires sont d'accord donc
concrètement les seuls bâtiments qui
sont réquisitionnés par exemple à Paris
ce sont les bâtiments dont la ville de
Paris est propriétaire nos gymnases ou
des établissements scolaires qui sont
vides parce qu'ils ont fermé ces
dernières années et donc c'est quand
même un peu frustrant quand on est élu
local d'être dans cette situation là et
donc ce que je dis c'est que si l'État
ne souhaite pas le faire qu'il donne au
moins la possibilité au maire de le
faire eux-mêmees je pense que ça ira
plus vite en tout cas ça ne pourra pas
aller plus lentement qu'aujourd'hui
puisque concrètement il se passe pas
grand-chose de ce côté-là je ne dis pas
que que que la réquisition est la
solution à tous les problèmes du
mallogement mais je dis que c'est dans
la gamme des possibilités qui se
présentent aux collectivités ça serait
une solution supplémentaire alors après
dans dans dans une société française où
je crois qu'il y a 6 français si ménag
sur 10 qui sont propriétaires le mot qui
réquisition tout de suite ça ça fait
figure des pventail quand même c'est la
raison pour laquelle je parlais de
bâtiment en vacance oui oui je parlais
pas d'un logement vide dans une
copropriété ou d'une résidence
secondaire dans une copro quand vous
avez un hôtel vide parfois depuis des
années c'est vrai que ça interroge
christophe Robert votre avis là-dessus
c'est ça serait un bon levier oui mon
avis juste si vous permettez c'est que
si ce bel objectif de 0 SDF qui doit
être prolongé je pense que la nation
doit le doit le porter
collectivement mais ne pas se tromper
c'est pas en ouvrant toujours plus de
place d'hébergement d'urence qu'on va
régler le problème c'est ce qu'on est en
train de
dire question c'estet domino dont on
parla absolument mais je prends
l'exemple quand même effectivement si on
accorda les titres de séjours à des
personnes qui travaillent dont les
enfants sont à l'école qui cotisent et
qui pourrai candidater au logement
social on on libérerait une partie et on
laisserait la place pour tous ceux qui
sont à la rue parce qu'on peut pas
laisser les gens comme ça à la rue mais
c'est pas seulement ce vecteur là qui
pourrait être utilisé il y a aujourd'hui
à Paris comme à Lyon ou à Marseille dans
l'hébergement d'urgence des personnes
qui ont une demande de logement social
en bonne et du forme et qui fautent
d'offre de logement disponible parce
qu'on a beaucoup baissé la production de
logements sociaux parce que les APL sont
moins performantes parce qu'il y a eu
des économies qui on été est faite
pendant 6 ans sur ces deux leviers de la
protection sociale ont plus de
difficultés à sortir vers le vers le
logement la réquisition Colan bressa est
un outil parmi d'autres mais qu'est-ce
qu'on demande aujourd'hui le ministre du
Logement qui était encore en place il y
a 10 jours Patrice vergrit avait annoncé
120 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour répondre aux besoins des personnes
à la rue bonne nouvelle sauf que il
suffit pas d'avoir une ligne dans le
ministère du logement ou au budget pour
que les choses se fassent nous ce qu'on
a demandé c'est les cellules d'urgence
piloté par les préfets pour ident tous
les bâtiments vides les lycées les
collèges éventuellement des bureaux
disponibles pour les aménager très
rapidement et mettre les personnes à
l'abri ça ne règlera pas le problème
durablement mais là les personnes sont à
la rue il faut les mettre à l'abri et
puis après voir avec elles où est-ce
qu'elles en sont qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi elles sont là ces familles
entrer dans leur histoire et ensuite les
accompagner durablement vers des
solutions plus dignes et plus durabl de
logement Julien dam est-ce que c'est pas
seulement une question d'argent c'est ce
que c'est ce que j'entends mais est-ce
qu'onpense est-ce qu'on dépense beaucoup
d'argent depuis 20 ans pour améliorer
finalement cette politique d'aide au au
sans-abri oui on dépense un argent
considérable ça veut pas dire qu'il est
en soit suffisant pour ce soir et ça
veut pas dire que on doit prendre sa
serpe et couper à l'intérieur de ces
budgets qui sont devenus considérables
quelques chiffres alors si on donne des
milliards personne ne se rend compte de
ce que c'est mais on a 3 milliards
d'euros de dépenses pour l'hébergement
généraliste qui était évoqué auquel il
faut ajouter 1 milliard d'euros pour
l'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile
donc on a 4 milliard 4 milliard d'EUR ça
équivaut à quoi par rapport à la dépense
totale de politique du logement c'est
plus de 10 % de la politique du logement
on peut faire plein de comparaisons et
après se bagarer sur le détail de tout
ce
que est-ce que la France est plutôt
généreuse elle est très généreuse c'est
ce que je voulais évoquer je suis allé
regarder dans les base de données
Eurostat Eurostat c'est l'INC européen
la France c'est 40 % des dépenses
d'hébergement de l'Union européenne post
brexit 40 % on peut se bagarrer c'est
pas exactement les mêmes nomenclatures h
h Gén et Paris est la ville la plus
généuse la micipalité et l'action de
l'État sur sur sur la municipalité sur
le ressort municipal bon mais ça ne
marche pas très bien donc ce n'est pas
qu'un sujet d'argent vraiment ça n'est
pas qu'un sujet d'argent c'est un sujet
de décision importante sur le plan des S
papiers à régulariser à mieux gérer pour
certains je crois qu'il faut aussi
imaginer la reconduite aux frontières
certainement pas les familles qui sont
là depuis 2 3 ans les gens qui
travaillent depuis des années et cetera
enfin c'est pas en faisant un plan de
régularisation massive que ou seulement
de régularisation que ceci fonctionnera
je pense qu'il y a un sujet de
décentralisation je suis content
d'entendre monsieur brossa dire que il
souhaite que des
dispositions qui sont à la main de
l'État soit confié à la municipalité en
l'espèce sur la réquisition c'est pas
forcément l'arme magique ça je suis tout
à fait d'accord mais que ce soit les
maires les élus locaux qui soient
pleinement responsable ça serait une
transformation puissante ouis est-ce
qu'il faut un ministère des des sansabri
au contraire je reprends ce que vous
disiez est-ce qu'il faut être de plus en
plus local ou pointilliste dans sa dans
dans la réponse d'abord moi je suis pas
du tout favorable à ce qu'on sépare le
sujet des sans-abriis du sujet du
logement en général parce que le
principal sujet c'est comment on permet
à des personnes qui sont à la rue ou en
centre d'hébergement d'accéder à un
logement c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs quand j'étais adjoint au
logement j'étais aussi adjint à
l'hébergement d'urgence la question pour
moi c'est le passage permettre à des
gens d'être hébergés parfois pourord
quelques nuit c'est quand même pas la
panassée c'est le c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire ensuite sur la question de
la décentralisation moi je suis très
très attaché au fait que sur les enjeux
du logement et de l'hébergement les
communes et davantage de compétences
mais pas qu'en matière d'hébergement en
matière de régulation du parc privé
aussi aujourd'hui on a des communes qui
sont complètement infantilisées quand
vous voulez encadrer les loyers par
exemple à Paris nous avons souhaité
encadrer les loyers d'autres villes je
vois il y a même des villes de l'autre
bord politique dans le Pays-Basque par
exemple qui souhait encadrer les loyers
mais on doit remplir un dossier auprès
de l'État
pour lui
demander remplir un certain nombre de
conditions pour pouvoir mettre en place
ce dispositif dispositif qui au final
d'ailleurs est mise en place par le
préfet c'est très infantilisant pourquoi
est-ce qu'on permet pas aux communes
elles-mêm de mettre en place ses règles
sans avoir amandier une autorisation de
l'État comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a annoncé son souhait d'une
loi de décentralisation sur le logement
si ça va dans ce sens-là nous nous y
sommes favor il nous reste quelques
minutes je voudrais qu'on parle quand
même du du 115 parce que en préparant
cette émission que ce soit dans le
report portage de de Samia de shfia ou
même dans les dans les éléments qu'
qu'on a pu récupérer il y a beaucoup de
constat négatif sur le 115 on voilà un
parmi d'autres le directeur territorial
de la Croix-Rouge s'appelle Boris
Robin la discuté c'est d'être là face à
la personne et lu dire bah est-ce que
vous AZ appelé le 115 oui j'ai appelé le
115 est-ce qu'il y a une place
d'hébergement non il y a pas place
d'hébergement et nous on n pas de
solution à vous proposer autres et c'est
ça la plus grosse difficulté pour tous
les bénévoles qui interviennent c'est de
laisser une personne à la rue sans
solution d'hébergement et et ça c'est
vraiment toujours très dur à vivre c'est
pour ça qu'on fait toujours le point
avec les bénévoles en fin de marude on
fait un débrief de façon à pouvoir
essayer de de se dire bah on a quand
même fait quelque chose on est quand
même allé voir la personne on a quand
même fait attention à elle on a quand
même gardé cette personne dans dans cet
esprit de de société de voilà donc on a
toujours cet esprit là mais ça reste
toujours le plus dur c'est de laisser
quelqu'un dehors Christoph Robert est-ce
que le 115 ne répond plus B en tout cas
il répond pas à tout le monde en octobre
on était à 8000 personnes qui appellent
le 115 qui ne se voit proposer aucune
solution le soir venu d'hébergement
d'urgence même pour une nuit dont 3000
enfants c'est les chiffres que vous
rappelez tout à l'heure il y a eu
quelques places qui ont été ouvertes en
France depuis donc ça a un petit peu
baissé mais on sait que dès que les
beaux jours vontevenenir ça va remonter
ça crée mais vous l'avez dit dans votre
sujet enfin c'était pointé dans votre
sujet ça crée une souffrance terrible
vous savez tout le travail social toute
l'action sociale c'estàd il y a la
souffrance des personnes qui appellent
évidemment et puis a tous ceux qui
accompagnent en disant mais nous on n
pas fait ça pour pour ça vous avez
aujourd'hui 2,4 millions de demandeurs
de logements sociaux on n jamais aussi
peu attribué de logements sociaux que
ces dernières années pour plein de
raisons faudrait faire deux émissions
sur le sujet mais évidemment le 115 mais
c'est la conséquence si vous voulez vous
voyez ce que je veux dire parce que
c'est c'est au bout de
Lael et donc les appelant du 115 ou ceux
qui font les MaroUes qui appellent les
115 ou d'ailleurs les citoyens parce
qu'on dit aux citoyens n'hésitez pas si
vous voyez quelqu'un en situation de
fragilité d'appeler le 115 mais faites
l'exercice faites l'exercice vous là
pendant 2 heur 3h et pour les raisons de
hiérarchisation encore une fois bien
normal aussi alors les enfants de moins
de 5 ans non oui plus une femme enceinte
de plus de 6 ans non je veux dire c'est
totalement on a des familles qui passent
2 heures au téléphone pour s'entendre
répondre ah bah non votre enfant est un
tout petit peu trop vieux c'est puisque
je voulais dire c'est qu'il y a des
profils qui savent très bien que de
toute façon ils seront les derniers
servic l'exemple type c'est l'homme seul
et quand vous l'avez indiqué à la nu la
solidarité à Paris vous voyez 77 % des
gens qui disent qu'il n'appellent même
plus de 115 nous dans les lieux
d'accueil pour la fondation abépierre en
moyenne toute l'année c'est à peu près
entre 50 et 70 % selon les villes de
personnes qui n'appellent plus le 115
c'est le seule thermomètre que nous
avant mais vous voyez bien que le
problème est beaucoup plus massif avec
beaucoup plus de souffrance que celle
qu'on est en train d' boss juste pour
bien comprendre c'est parce que il y a
pas assez de personnes pour répondre ou
parce que le 115 a pas assez de place
d'hébergement à proposer au au sansabri
c'est parce qu'on manque de place
d'hébergement très concrètement c'est
pas une réorganisation du 115 qu'il faut
qu' faut engagero non non en
l'occurrence toutes les places sont
pleines le problème c'est pas qu'on a du
mal à les remplir le problème c'est
qu'on manque de place pour héberger les
personnes qui appellent d'accord votre
avis là-dessus Julien d'Amon est-ce
qu'il faut alors c'est c'est quoi c'est
ouvrir des places d'émergement pour que
le 115 soit plus efficace évidemment dit
comme ça ça a l'air ça a l'air très
facile sauf que ça n'est pas si simple
je suis adepte et c'est facile dans ma
position parce que je ne suis pas aux
affaires de solution radical je pense
qu'il faut supprimer le 115 bom je vais
me faire gronderé pourquoi le 115 a été
créé il y a un quart de siècle à peu
près pour justement que la popul ulation
puisse signaler la présence de personnes
à la rue et à l'époque c'était plutôt ce
profil de Messieurs abîmés par
l'existance seul ça n'a pas fonctionné
globalement ça a dérivé pour devenir ce
que c'est aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire un
système qui ne fonctionne pas on est
d'accord pour dire que ça ne fonctionne
pas de réservation hôtelière parce que
ceon ce nous sommes en train de parler
c'est de l'attribution de place dans des
hôtels financés par l'État pour des
familles pour des personnes isolées qui
n'ont pas de place ailleurs alors la
seul quelle proportion de de de d'hôel
les plac
d'hôtel sur S demande c'est quoi c'estes
20 places d'hôtel c'est 30 places
d'hôtel sans demande les demandes il
demandent pas une place d'ôtel il demand
une place d'ébergementite quand quand on
quand on dis ce dont dispose le Sami
social puisqu'on parle du Sami social
pour l'Î de France qui gère le 115 c'est
de ce soir 60000 places d'hôtel mais
elles sont pleines ces places d'hôtel
mon sujet c'est pas ça c'est que quand
on parle du 115 tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que c'est
infantilisant c'est indigne pour ceux
qui appellent comme pour ceux qui
reçoivent des des des conversations
terribles parce qu' au bout du fil
quelqu'un qui vous dit bah ce soir je
sais pas où dormir je suis avec un
enfant et cetera vous êtes en train de
dire bah non benah rappelez demain ou
rappeler dans 3 semaines enfin et ceter
donc c'est ça ne marche pas le seul
argument c'est de dire c'est un
thermomètre voilà donc on a un
thermomètre pour un truc qui fonctionne
pas moi je pense que ça ne sert
strictement à
rien d'AB la première chose c'est que la
France est toujours fascinante pour dire
ah bah on on a un truc on a un
thermomètre ça n'existe nulle part tout
le monde ve bien mettre tout le monde
dans du logement on est tout à fait
d'accord oui non mais enfin non ce qu'il
faudrait avoir c'est quelle est
l'alternative que vous proposez je pense
que le SC ne sert à rien voilà c'est
assez clair de mon point V il sert à
quoi allez-y aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
est en difficulté parce que nous avons
pas ass place nous l'avons dit en début
d'émission si ce secteur de
l'hébergement subit cette pression là
c'est qu'il y a des défaillances de
politique public en amont et en aval on
a pas de solution ne répond à rien il
répond pas aux gens il répond pas au
problèm il répond pas à rien mais si JIS
si jamais on devait envisager autre
chose c'est un accès direct au logement
parce que tout le monde a besoin accès
direct à l'ébergement pour commencer oui
ah
ou for
parber juliam tout à l'heure c'est parmi
l'ensemble des plac d'hébergement et
parmi l'ensemble des plac d'hébergement
d'urgence la variable d'ajustement de
ces dernières années ça a été les places
d'hôtel et c'est vrai que ça coûte cher
à la collectivité et c'est pas le bon
accompagnement pour les personnes vous
pouvez pas forcément cuisiner vous
pouvez pas inviter qui vous voulez on
connait ces études là donc c'est pas
digne pour les personnes et c'est pas
efficace du point de vue des politiques
publiques je parle des places en hôtel
donc la politique du logement d'abord
justement comme le font les finlandais
comme le font un certain nombre de pays
de villes nord-américaines de dire au
lieu de faire passer par deshébergement
d'urgence d'insertion la rue et cetera
on va essayer de faire un accès direct
au logement parce que c'est ça qui va
permettre aux personnes de se
reconstruire mais là il faudra faire une
émission sur
les moi j'ai l'impression qu'il faut
revenir aussi au parcours individuel
parce que là on a l'impression que avec
ces objectifs de 0 SDF et cette
progression que on a l'impression qu'on
est blasé que les sociétés modernes
fabriquent ça et que enfin moi
excusez-moi
touche ou une femme dehors dans des
situations et on a l'impression ah c'est
pas grave on y arrive pas bien oh il y a
beaucoup de choses à travailler mais bon
toute façon ça augmente et on a toujours
des promesses et ça marche toujours il
faut revenir peut-être à ces parcours
individuels d'où la connaissance
peut-être et c'est bien de d'aller voir
plus loin pourquoi ils sont là pourquoi
on n arrive pas c'est vrai que les les
chambres d'hôtel ça fait un peu une
image aussi très compliqué quand on cour
quand on fait demandeur d'asile chambre
d'hôtel là ça fabrique aussi des images
compliquées pour la société française
est politiquement difficilement
politiquement difficilement acceptable
mais moi il me semble qu'il faut revenir
quand même pas une séquence émotion mais
quand même à des parcours individuels
qui sont très très durs et on peut pas
accepter ça nos sociétés modernes sont
quand même plutôt pour le bien-être
humain on peut pas accepter qu'il y a
autant de gens qui soi l'émission est
finie vous avez 10 secondes ouais le
sujet clé c'est l'équilibre entre
l'émotion et la raison allez on termine
là-dessus merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
évidemment à bientôt sur sur Public
Sénat voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission je vous donne rendez-vous
demain 18h et 22h et puis notez que
l'invité de la matinale ce sera Yannick
jado sénateur Europe Écologie Les ver de
Paris belle
soirée